hello welcome to the plane gender I
under we'll see what happens not much it
seems ok now he plays a move I could do
something else though just very often
playing the five nowadays what to
practice my openings a little bit n
don't play such a wide variety of
openings anymore in the games ok so I've
got someone slowish society in here
Craven again slough oops Queen to be 60
move Queen B 6 and then taking on b2 is
this one of those famous last words kind
of situations this could not be five
though it's the kind of tan tanga it
really is night see to be five I castle
sits wrapping the Queen but look be one
tween a to it looks it looks very very
dangerous so ah losing lots of time with
stuff like that we now I'm definitely
threatening this but he will play but
should be three or king edge one or
something sorry and then this is not
important anymore ok
Quinn to eat too it looks like very a
wood fashioned way of playing the is
playing this this line yeah you might
have you five sorry for my voice gotta
slide cord yeah what's the deal in five
no it doesn't do it so if i go queen to
before is that annoying maybe slightly
rupee 10 that's not an ideal move let's
block the c5 business
hmm ok well I can take a d5 and I can
take a form or a phone but this looks
quite tasty just a full pawn their on f4
they don't quite see the compensation
don't see any dangerous looking and
discoveries for example ok so we
prevented Queen to see for which
definitely was a serious option ok let's
do this prevent poncy form
defines us okay hmm so maybe just f5
yeah let's grab the space queen to
before as always possible in case of
let's say Bishop e3 or Bishop g3 and
threatening efore probably doesn't hood
check don't see why I shouldn't
white person's yep I mean you just
blunder that pawn to put it down to one
single single sentence that Queen B 6
was quite stupid problem that I have
studied this for so long because this is
just looking tremendously dangerous yeah
i saw that i couldn't really figure out
if my queen gets trapped but probably it
does after castling rupee one commune
here so how is the queen getting trapped
with this this this this and this okay
yeah I cacti didn't see it but again I
decided to not take it here it looks
fairly like a fairly normal position TM
yeah sometimes one can play a five in
response to that effect but I don't
think it works here i thinkI I just I
just take things yeah so we decided to
capture himself and now Bishop f2 yeah
here it seems that if five is becoming a
serious idea so this is why I went queen
before first and then each five next you
could have played this immediately
though oh I didn't really pay attention
to that the engine thinks I'm okay after
this move here but it's not something
that I have planned and I don't quite
get it though I have this one Wow okay I
probably should have done that now I
mean I can't even take a 4 that's what
the engine is given what this move is
also good let's just make sure that the
bishops are not doing much and I have
this lined up as an idea yet this just
this just doesn't work it gives me the
air for porn and with it a fantastic
central control you know can learn that
this this in addition but in the
position already was
yeah was very bad it's a just probably
not a playable position after the f porn
is dropping okay well thanks for
watching